ein kontrollfreak
meine mutter ist so neugierig
sie ruft mich 100 mal am tag an
sie will die ganze zeit wissen wo ich
bin
dani wo bist du
[Musik]
ich bin in der apotheke
wo bist du
in der bar
[Musik]
wo bist du
im kino
im restaurant
wo bist du
im krankenhaus
im
supermarkt
wo bist du
im lob
im club
[Musik]
gebäude geschäfte
ich bin im plus da tief
in der apotheke
der bar
im kino
restaurant
im krankenhaus
supermarkt
im club
meine mutter kontrolliert mich immer
sie ist paranoid
bonnie ich bin besorgt
donny ich bin besorgt
wo bist du
ich bin bei tom
katja
[Musik]
wo bist du
bei der immer
bei der oma
wo bist du
beim opa
beim arzt
wo bist du
bei den freunden
bei mir
personen ich bin bei plus dativ
bei tom
katja
bei der oma
beim opa
beim arzt
bei den freunden
bei mir
es macht ihr nichts aus mich zu stören
dani es ist schon spät
wo bist du
[Musik]
ich bin auf der party
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auf dem konzert
[Applaus]
auf dem filmfestival
veranstaltungen
ich bin auf plus dativ
auf der party
auf dem konzert
auf dem filmfestival
dani wo bist du
auf dem balkon
wo bist du
auf dem dach
auf dem markt
wo bist du
auf dem sportplatz
offene plätze
ich bin auf plus dativ
auf dem balkon
auf dem dach
auf dem markt
auf dem sportplatz
ruft mich zu den unmöglichsten zeiten an
sie ruft mich zu den unmöglichsten
zeiten an
dornier ich bin sehr beunruhigt
gorny ich bin sehr beunruhigt
wo bist du
ich bin beim essen
beim lesen
lesen
wo bist du
beim joggen
wo wirst du
beim einkaufen
aktivitäten ich bin bei plus dativ
beim essen
beim lesen
beim joggen
beim einkaufen
sie bringt mich in peinliche situationen
dani wo bist du
ich schaue immer auf die uhr
ich bin auf der bank
wo bist du
auf der post
[Musik]
wo bist du
an der kasse
an der ecke
an der bushaltestelle
wo bist du
an der universität
achtung es gibt ausnahmen
auf der bank
auf der post
an der kasse
der ecke
der bushaltestelle
an der universität
sie macht mein
zu einem albtraum
sie macht mein leben zu einem albtraum
toni ich sorge mich um dich
wo bist du
ich bin am flughafen
am bahnhof am bahnhof
im zug
[Musik]
wo bist du
im flugzeug
auf dem schiff
achtung es gibt ausnahmen
am flughafen
bahnhof
im zug
im flugzeug
auf dem schiff
ich kann mich nirgends vor ihr
verstecken
dani ich mache mir sorgen um dich
da nie ich mache mir sorgen um dich
[Musik]
wo bist du
in europa
[Musik]
wo bist du
in asien
in china
wo bist du
in indien
in london
wo bist du
in rom
kontinente länder städte
ich bin in
in europa
in asien
in china
in indien
in london
in rom
achtung es gibt ausnahmen
der schweiz
in der ukraine
der slowakei
der türkei
im irak
iran
[Musik]
im sudan
den usa
reinigt den arabischen emiraten
in den niederlanden
meine mutter ist ein kontrollfreak
downey ich bin krank vor sorge
dani ich bin krank vor sorge
wo bist du
am meer
am strand
wo bist du
auf der insel
auf dem berg
achtung es gibt ausnahmen
mehr
auf der insel
auf dem berg
wo bist du
in den bergen
im wald
[Musik]
wo bist du
im weltraum
[Musik]
wo bist du
im paradies
in der hölle
wo bist du
zuhause
zu hause
achtung es gibt ausnahmen
in den bergen
im wald
im weltraum
im paradies
hölle
zu hause
ich habe keine ahnung warum sie so
nervös ist
mama ich bin bei der arbeit
achtung es gibt ausnahmen
bei der arbeit
meine mutter macht mich verrückt
ich kann nicht mehr damit leben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hat dir das video gefallen abonniere
unseren kanal